[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday Hank I
know it's not even my day to update but
I just had to tell you thank you thank
you thank you for that amazing two-day
birthday present I mean I don't think
anyone in all of human history has ever
gotten a birthday present like that like
even Oprah Winfrey doesn't have
birthdays like that my birthday this
year was better than Oprah Winfrey's
best birthday ever
I mean obviously thank you to the
nerdfighters but Hank I just have to
thank you in particular because I know
how much work went into everything you
did and it just means so much to me
thank you thank you thank you you're
welcome John
hey tink and once again we have pulled a
fast one on the nerdfighters you may
have noticed for the last couple days I
haven't been appearing and I haven't
been saying what I'm going to see John
next because I saw John on Sunday and it
would have been very obvious if I had
said John I will see you on Sunday man
I'm really disappointed that you went
and got a haircut John without me and
now I have this hair and we can't go and
have like tag-team Brotherhood a haircut
time which would be awesome especially
because I would like much less hair be I
should put it in a ponytail Katherine
can you give me a hair tie this is
better he's got on my eyes anyway John
I'm at your house uh you were downstairs
writing your book we've been writing
feverishly since I arrived I appreciate
you taking your time to visit with me
even though you have a quite a deadline
coming up best of luck with that that is
one of my pants and I wrote a post from
a guy who says that I should stop
talking about my hair and then I
realized that I was talking about my
hair again now I'm sad so IVA spend too
much time talk about my hair I mean
mostly it's because I see it so much
when I'm looking at myself in the camera
and it seems like there's a lot of it
but I'm talking about my hair again
anyway John I'm very excited to be here
at your house it's really really nice
I'm having a bit of a hard time like I
kind of want to live here there's room
for me lots of room for me so maybe I
just won't leave
and it's really nice that the Eddie and
Katherine are both here and our parents
are also here they just arrived like
five minutes ago so I've finished this
video so I can go hang out with our
parents there's one piece of art in
particular that I would like to share
with the nerdfighters just above the
toilet in the guest bedroom remember the
girl who was waiting for you give her a
square deal keep clean now those were
the days when we used to be so subtle
about prophylactics and prostitution you
know what I hate is when people are like
looking over your shoulder when you're
doing something like when you're making
a video and you know that they're there
like watching you do something and that
was the first cameo by my dad ever but
it's kind of hard to make the videos
when there's people all around um that's
something I should just get over done
and I would both like to thank all the
nerdfighters who helped us out with the
most recent secret project I don't think
that it will be the last secret project
John and I are working on an idea and
there will be more about that later this
week there were also be more brotherhood
togetherness specials John I will see
you probably 5 or 10 minutes when you're
finished and I'm looking forward to
hanging out all week